estado de emergencia en el sur de Perú
el departamento de Arequipa es el más
afectado por las intensas lluvias que
han provocado mortales deslizamientos
conocidos localmente Como huaicos
en el pueblo de secocha y zonas aledañas
del municipio de Mariano Nicolás
valcárcel decenas de personas murieron
son más de mil familias damnificadas no
donde se puede decir que de un 90%
ya no tiene validez sus viviendas no ha
sido completamente destruidas los
huaicos también son graves en carbélica
Maná los residentes angustiados por la
magnitud del desastre claman por ayuda
un desastre completo ya Y tenemos
ahorita cuerpos regados están muertos el
Ministerio de defensa anunció el
despliegue de equipos de búsqueda y
rescate vía aérea debido al bloqueo de
las carreteras helicóptero del ejército
de Perú partido del Fuerte zamacola
hacia camaná trasladando autoridades
regi y ayuda humanitaria consistente en
agua y sacos Terreros entre otros
unos kilómetros al norte el río pisco
uno de los principales afluentes de la
costa peruana también preocupa a los
organismos de rescate sus aguas han
alcanzado un caudal de hasta 234 metros
cúbicos por segundo mientras que
ayacucho cusco y junín están en alerta
Roja La catástrofe natural ocurre en un
momento convulso en Perú especialmente
en el sur del país epicentro de las
manifestaciones contra el gobierno de
Dina boluarte la presidenta viajó a las
zonas afectadas